thank you so much for join us than this
is a difficult time now as
you c isra are
from in gaz and you have said
you c of isra the pain tce
once
isra نعم نحن من جهه مواطنون اسرائيليون
جزء من المجتمع الاسرائيلي وجزء من دوله
اسرائيل ومن جهه اخرى نحن جزء من الشعب
العربي الفلسطيني وبالتالي نسعى دائما الى
التوازن بين هويتنا الوطنيه من جهه
وهويتنا المدنيه من جهه ونحاول ان نتواصل
بشكل ايجابي مع كوننا مواطنين في اسرائيل
نتضامن مع المجتمع الاسرائيلي ونشعر بالمه
ونشعر بااله واحلامه وايضا نتضامن مع
الشعب الفلسطيني ونشعر بالامه وطموحاته
ونسعى ان نكون في توازن ما بين المدني وما
بين الوطني ما بين الاسرائيلي وما بين
الفلسطيني
نعم نحن نريد للحرب ان تتوقف ونريد
ل العمليات العسكريه ان تتوقف ولكن نريد
لهذا الصراع العربي الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
ان يصل الى نهايته وان يحل السلام نحن لا
نتعامل فقط مع اللحظه الحاليه نتعامل مع
المستقبل ولا نريد ان نبقى في الماضي
المطلوب ليس فقط وقف لاطلاق النار او هدنه
لايام مقابل تبادل اسرى ولكن نريد ان نرى
مبادره سياسيه حقيقيه تحقق
الاهداف المشروعه للطرفين
وتسمح لنا باعاده التفكير الجدي بانهاء
هذا الصراع واحلال السلام ضمن دائره حل
الدولتين الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه الى
جانب بعضهما
البعض ا لقائي مع العائلات المخطوفين كان
لقاء عاطفي وتعبير عن تعاطفي وتضامني معهم
هذه حاله انسانيه يجب ان نعبر فيها عن عن
دعمنا لبعضنا البعض خصوصا لهذه العائلات
وانا عرضت مساعدتي لهم وكل ما طلبوه مني
قمت به ابتداء من ان اوجه رساله باسمي
واسمهم الى الرئيس جو بايدن والى الرئيس
اردوغان والى امير قطر والى كل الجهات
التي تؤثر في في هذه المساله فقمت يعني
بالنشاط في هذا الجانب دعما لحقهم المشروع
في ان
يعيدوا ابناهم سالمين الى بيوتهم وانا
يعني الحمد لله بالامس كل العائلات التي
التقيت معها قد استقبلوا ابنائهم في في
بيوتهم من
جديد
انا من جديد اريد ان اوضح بشكل
قاطع اي اعتداء على حياه الابرياء على
حياه المدنيين الاطفال النساء كبار السن
واختطافهم هذا عمل محرم او ممنوع حسب
قيمنا ايضا الاسلاميه وقيم الانسانيه ويجب
ادانه هذا الامر ويمنع ان نبرر هذه
الاعمال من جهه اخرى هنالك صراع سياسي يجب
ان يح يحل بالطرق السياسيه السلميه ولكن
الموقف هنا يجب ان يكون موقف اخلاقي وموقف
انساني بشكل كامل
اي انا الاحظ انه خلال كل هذه السنه سوات
العمليات المسلحه لم تاتي باي خير او باي
فائده للشعب الفلسطيني ولاحظنا انه في كل
مره يكون فيها استخدام للقوه المسلحه
الشعب الفلسطيني يكون ضحيه ويدفع اثمان
باهضه اكثر من 15000 ضحيه فلسطينيه جراء
هذه الاعمال ولذلك انا اعتقد
انه فصائل المسلحه
الفلسطينيه يجب ان تكف عن استخدام السلاح
وان تنضوي في مشروع سياسي مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه من اجل تعزيز فرص اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه وفرض سيادتها واعلان وقف كامل
ودائم لاطلاق النار نحو احلال السلام
وانهاء هذا
الصراع
بدايه انا اقترح على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التي وضعت اهداف لهذا الحرب ان تضع ايضا
تطلق ايضا مشروع
سياسي ينسجم مع اهداف الحرب بطرق سياسيه
وليس بطرق عسكريه هذا مطلوب على ضوء
النتائج الوخيمه التي كانت في النصف الاول
من هذه الحرب
والضحايا الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين من
جهه اخرى نتيجه لهذا الحرب لذلك انا اعتقد
انه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ملزمه بالاضافه الى مسار الحرب ان تعطي
مسار بديل للحرب تضع فيه اهدافها السياسيه
انهاء حكم حماس وانهاء قوه العسكريه لحماس
ولكن ان تطرح مشروع سياسي في هذا
الاتجاه ولكن ما بعد الحرب تصوري انه الحل
الواقعي هو ان نعزز من قوه السلطه
الفلسطينيه مجلس الامن الدولي يجب ان يعطي
اعتراف فوري بدوله
فلسطينيه مستقله الى جانب دوله اسرائيل
هذه الدوله الفلسطينيه واجبها الاول ان
تجمع السلاح وان ان تمنع اي فصائل مسلحه
فلسطينيه وان تعمل مع المجتمع الدولي على
اعاده بناء قطاع غزه
وتاهيل هذا القطاع و العمل على ايضا نشر
ثقافه السلام والتوجه السلام اجاه
الاسرائيليين بمعنى انه في واجب اسرائيلي
وواجب فلسطيني الواجب الاسرائيلي هو
الاستعداد لحل سياسي سلمي والواجب
الفلسطيني نزع السلاح من الفصائل المسلحه
كجزء من تجسيد مبدا سياده الدوله
الفلسطينيه والاعتراف بها